Malcolm Gladwell is a longtime writer
for The New Yorker he's been named one
of the 100 most influential people by
Time magazine
so it's Charlie rules just saying he's
much more deserving than I am I don't
know about that that's not true he's
also the author of five New York Times
bestsellers including the tipping point
outliers and David and Goliath
now Gladwell is back with the second
season of us podcast it's called
revisionist history the series looks at
events and ideas from the past that have
been overlooked or misunderstood Malcolm
Gladwell joins us once again at the
table congratulations on season 2 Thank
You Gail but is this it I love your
start of season 2 it's about private
golf courses in Los Angeles and you said
you described the golf course as crack
cocaine for rich white guys now before
you comment rich white guy the tape
playing golf yes I do so be careful how
you answer I'm gonna because what you
talking about Malcolm well I you know I
have little fun with the game of golf
yes you do and I point out just how much
golf is played by rich white guys uh-huh
but I'm more interesting about women as
well yes yes I'm more interested in a
larger question using the private golf
courses of LA as an example of how is
privilege protected and enshrined in
American society and though the private
golf course is a valet are a fascinating
example about how a very small group of
very wealthy people have managed to
essentially not pay any property taxes
for generations on these huge golf
courses in the middle of the city and
nobody else gets to play on it no way
Natalie on it and la is a city that is
one of the has some of the fewest amount
of parkland of any major American city
it is under parked yes and so I was I
would go to LA and I would be confronted
by this weird fact which is I'm a runner
there's nowhere to run in LA and yet
there are these 300 acre there's like
six or seven private golf courses that
take up hundreds of acres and they have
big chain-link fences and you pointed
out that nobody was on the course and
why can you go out there and walk around
can I go in yeah so that started me
thinking though about this question of
how privilege gets embedded in the
structure of our society it's one of
those what I'm trying to do with the
with the podcast
is to use these kind of very seemingly
light-hearted questions to examine much
more important subject because of these
bizarre legal developments in the case
of the laa golf courses but it becomes a
jumping-off point for you to talk to
landscape architects talk to
philosophers to go just about anywhere
you want to go with these issues right
there was a moment when I was making
that when I was making that episode when
I just had this I was like I need to
talk to a philosopher this is getting so
complicated so I called this guy at the
University of Washington Mark Cohen who
is so much fun and it's it was one of
those things you could do in a podcast
there's no rules you know you could just
if you want to talk about a philosopher
you can talk to a blog that's what I
love about the forum it's there's
something but talk about what you
learned about the CEO's that play golf
and how their companies are doing I
thought that was really interesting yeah
there's a there's a there's an economist
named lead Baker staff who did this
really lovely work using the fact that
if you're a serious golfer you post your
scores on the USGS website right so you
can calculate your handicap and so what
he did is he looked at all of the people
who had posted their scores and matched
it to a list of CEOs of public companies
and was able to figure out how much CEOs
play golf and then he was at he was able
to figure out what effect does playing
golf have on the performance of your
company and first of all he showed that
CEOs play an astonishing amount of golf
and the more golf you play the worse
your company does so it's like at
shareholder meetings people should stand
up and say excuse me so do you think
therefore that the country did badly
because President Obama loved to play
golf no I all I will say this that I
would I'd be happier if presidents as a
group played less golf and spent more
time mastering the details of their
presidency but I've nothing against
people doing sports for recreation
what am i my problem is when a
particular addiction to a certain sport
affects the rest of us and affects the
citizens of Los Angeles they don't have
any place
to go and you know there's no park space
available for them to play I don't have
any but I'm agree with you know any
problems all you saying I just think
that the idea of people being able to
get outside
yeah I'm run yeah we'll play golf just
do something in the complex world today
that's a very good thing yeah I'm not
going to disagree with that you also did
something about McDonald's how
McDonald's broke your heart with a food
item that I thought Malcolm Gladwell I
was stunned that you eat McDonald's
let's just start with that after its run
yes but there is something at McDonald's
that broke your heart back in 1990 yes
they changed the recipe for the French
fries yes those of us who are old enough
to remember what a McDonald's french
fried tasted like back in the day we'll
know it used to be amazing right they
were that's why you went to McDonald's
they were the most incredible fries
you've ever eaten and they are not
anymore and they are not anymore for a
reason and that is that McDonald's
changed the formula on July 23rd 1990
and I think that that formula change was
catastrophic and you brought in
Millennials to do a blind taste test and
even they pick the old fried it is funny
I got went to the I went to America's
leading R&D house and had to make me
fries the old way in the new way and we
did a blind taste test the old way and
almost one person there's no one yeah
taste the old fries and the new fries
you thinking should it we've done this
one right here actually Malcolm Gladwell
the first season is worth listening to
the second season of revisionist history
is available now